lancée au triple galop jeu sans battre
mon coeur dans cette course folle d'un
amant tous tes pieds j'ai la place où la
lumière et la sincérité ne me fait pas
alors tu es là c'est l'autriche annonce
et agathe ont reconnu sa voix aux
tricheries ouais attendront commun ce
qui est là c'est l'autriche
l'autriche qui l'autriche tanoh
pourquoi
[Musique]
là je vous danser un petit peu toutes
les deux la wii non mais c'est bon parce
que la lay line décoincer la frontera
eneryo mais c'est vrai allez allez allez
non mais les coincer les choses vous la
chaude et vous ciblez jeu-là schwab la
chaudière je suis ton jeu ça te laisse
partie musique ou les arts c'est comme
ça que tu chantes
[Musique]
je vais
c'est
à l'asie
nous en avons assez critique
la une face à la caméra
la descente est restée sur mer
l'at elle est sublime et c'est la plus
belle du monde senior avant de se dire
des conneries non les jolies mais moi
franchement pour vous ça fait le lui dis
en l'ol mais là je suis complètement
soutient le travail est un bon 14 sur 20
ha oui tu as bien faire un petit bisou à
l'origine
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous pourriez faire un bisou
sur la bouche à enora mais pas ici bas
alors maintenant si c'est chez vous
qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ]
on a envie de qui fait un peu on est
bientôt là voilà c'est bientôt la fin de
la semaine
on est tous fatigués on a coûté souci on
en a tous pleins la tête
on n'a plus tous en vie voilà vous
n'êtes pas malade n'est pas de nom
vous n'êtes pas malade
non mais je me propose de te ramener
après une mission noble n'y a pas de
ramener à personne avant qu'elle soit
ici
je suis en couple est alors elle aussi
ne voulons pas la vedette à malte et de
leur mandat mais rester en couple aussi
mais oui on veut c'est bon alors non
mais c'est vrai ça sert mais elle elle
veut pas rien c'est un petit agathe
borne est la raison pour être pas pour
nous c'est pas grand chose pour elle ça
veut dire beaucoup
merci merci de cas merci merci à toi
soya qui la merci à huy à gâteau prou au
scoop fait bondir
enfin ça lâche qu'on fait ce soir mais
la tristesse va regarder je croyais que
j'allais dire un truc super intelligent
m'a fait ça va schtroumpfer ce soir à
gap
mais c'est que vous pouvez regarder
jean-michel et lui dire en anglais vous
avez très envie de coucher avec lui ce
soir jean-michel hayat qu'elle a envie
de lui mais mauvais le saurons bientôt
si je ne suis pas envie de mettre ses
chaussures est alors voulu répondre à la
moquer hockey